Britany you've been in the media for a
long time in television for many decades
when you saw sem nunberg on yesterday
did you think to yourself i would have
put him on if I were bureau chief or I
wouldn't have put him on if I were
bureau chief
well I very much hope Tucker that I
would not have and it was worth noting
this before the day was over CNN's Erin
Burnett had looked at him and said I
smell liquor on your breath could she
have been the first and only seeing
anchor to notice that the guy was
probably drunk not only that he is
plainly a very troubled soul and you
know there's a journalist when you come
along you don't have to make a
psychiatric diagnosis to recognize that
somebody you're talking to may not be
you know ok and that whatever this
person says may be indeed questionable
and yet yet this guy held sway over the
airwaves you pointed out earlier for
hours on end particularly on CNN but I
guess others picked it up and it got
quite a ride yesterday and of course the
principal thing that made the headline
sucker was when he said that he wasn't
going to cooperate with Muller well by
this morning that was all gone and he
said indeed he was gonna cooperate with
Muller as a matter of fact he had very
very little choice but that was a
non-story that that lived all day long
because it feeds this whole narrative
that there's something terribly wrong
and that we have an unqualified
president under the influence of Russia
and God knows what else
and so to make that point you have
someone who's done the influence of
alcohol to jump around the set and
humiliate himself but not only that
degrade the person who's interviewing
him I mean I wonder if there's a cost
long-term when you do stuff like that
well you know I think Tucker what we're
looking at here is that there's a
there's been a belief for the longest
time that the Trump election was
illegitimate and there's been a sense in
the media that his election constitutes
a kind of national emergency because he
is such a such an unqualified character
and so likely to lead us off a cliff
that it is a job of the media to join
the resistance and to find out what must
be behind his election what's candles
must lurk there in order really to take
him down all right I mean I think that's
plainly what this is all about the media
clearly joined the resistance and the
and the coverages of this I think has
been in the mainstream media t it's
extremely one-sided a lot of it
misguided they've been
you know any number of stories that
turned out badly all along the way
remember famously CNN the group of their
senior people sitting around and saying
that they had word that when Comey
testified that he was going to testify
that he'd never told Donald Trump that
that he was not under investigation then
the next day of course Comey came out
and testified just the opposite you
wonder how stories like that and there
been several of them can possibly get
past these seasoned journalists if
they're not only kind of crusade and I
think they are yeah I remember when the
Russians hashed hack the national power
grid do you think it might help but they
didn't of course do you think it might
help the rest of us who were getting
agitated watching this just to remind
ourselves that what you're seeing is
political advocacy there's no
expectation of objectivity or news you
know what you're watching is one side
waging partisan battle against the other
yeah and and but you know it's
strikingly effective I mean your
previous guest you know she really
didn't want to let go of the narrative
that's out there that Russia had an
important effect on the election the
evidence of that as you point out it was
extremely extremely light at best and
you know anything that Russia did to the
tune of you in a million dollars a month
is dwarfed by the rest of the spending
and the other things that influence the
outcome of elections and you know it's
but it's it's something that is held on
to for dear life and I think it's
distorted coverage
I think it's enraged the people who see
things more clearly than that but on and
on it goes that you see it particularly
in the character assassination of Devon
known as the chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee who's had to put
up with unbelievable assaults on him and
they continued this day that he is the
guy who's at fault when you know that on
the Democratic side feeding the press
there's this unbelievable leak fest out
of that committee and it goes on and on
not a bad moment to the Americanization
goodman Heilmann over at MSNBC called
núñez quote a Russian agent I mean you
would get fine two years ago you be
fired for saying something like that if
you couldn't support it but he's
obviously just so it's an it borders on
hysteria I mean it's just so over the
top I mean you don't have to be a Trump
admired to realize that the things that
are being said or just are just wildly
out of proportion to anything real
beneath them well it's insane I know
people who hate
trap who agree with that completely the
honest one Brit thank you very much
you bet Tucker